the stamp duty holiday is being
extended now it's not official but it's
been announced it's happening
so the stamp duty holiday was supposed
to end on the 1st of april however it's
now been announced
it's going to be extended until the end
of june
what does that mean that means that now
if you're a first time buyer you'll pay
no stamp duty
on a house that you buy that's less than
500 000 pounds
if you're an investor it's gonna be
fixed at three percent so stamp duty is
gonna be
less for longer which is a really really
good thing i'm very glad this has
happened and the reason i'm glad
and by the way there are some
disadvantages depending on who you are
what side of the coin you're on
um but generally speaking i'm really
pleased about this because
over the last year house prices have
been really booming and
a lot of people have been making a lot
of money winners on a wednesday every
week i have a winner on a wednesday
and they come on the show because the
house market's been booming
everything else is struggling business
in general is really bad but
house market's been going really well i
was predicting
that as soon as the i said this last
year i said look as soon as the stamp
duty ends
and as soon as the furlough scheme ends
which they're also it's looking like
they're going to extend as well for
another few months
and i don't know if they're going to
keep extending this i guess it all
depends on
how long the lockdown lasts now they're
saying that the lockdown is going to be
completely lifted
by the 21st of june i hope that is the
case but we don't know for sure
but i imagine until the lockdown is
completely lifted we're going to keep
having furlough we're going to keep
having the stamp duty holiday
and what's that what that what's
happening is through the pandemic
the housing market's booming right now
the average house that goes on right
move sales within 49 days it used to be
67. so houses are sling a lot quicker
which is great if you're wanting to buy
and sell a house also
first time buyers are queuing up for
properties now the reason this can be a
bad thing
is because if you're an investor it is
sometimes harder to find a deal right
now
because the market's going up and there
is there has been a lot of criticism
over the stamp duty holiday namely the
criticism has been
and the thing is you can criticize
anything if it wasn't for the stamp duty
holiday
in april when the lockdown first
happened the housing market you couldn't
view houses
you weren't allowed to view houses
everything paused there's over half a
million properties
where the sale was paused and to be
honest it was a nightmare
and i was pulling my hair out and
business was really tough
but then they lifted the lock down for
the housing market and said you're
allowed to view houses as long as you
you know abide by the rules so i've been
and a lot of people have hated uh hated
me for it but i've been
buying lots of houses i've been viewing
lots of houses i've been doing business
as usual
to some extent on the on the property
side sticking to the rules
social distancing etc um we've been
making lots of money we've had lots of
houses going through
we've been buying we've been selling and
the property market has been crazy
so um the reason i think i'm really
pleased about the holidays it means that
that's going to continue to happen
happen there's going to be more boom
there's going to be more opportunities
right up until the summer and if you've
been scared
if you've been thinking for the last six
months oh but it's going to suddenly end
and
oh i don't know i'll wait and see look
you may as well get
in now you know the market is booming
now the criticism that people have been
saying
is that number one um i think the
the fact that first time buyers are
thinking that the stamp duty holiday is
great because it's going to save them on
stamp duty
but then they're paying more for the
houses because he's pushing the house
prices up
so i think people are latching on to the
fact that actually
although we're saving on stamp because
house prices are going up it's making it
harder for first-time buyers
you know rents are going up house prices
are going up so
it is making it harder for first-time
buyers for investors i guess it is a
good thing
um you know we we we of course want the
market booming
we want rents going up and we you know i
mean i've been getting a lot of stick
actually the um
northern independence party i saw you
know bashing me on twitter there are
i haven't looked into too much political
party you know bashing me
for buying houses and renting them out
up north when i don't live up north
because apparently it's
you know they need to free the north and
all that but i'm thinking that doesn't
make any sense because
i'm actually number one creating homes
for people that want to rent
affordable homes um number two
i'm teaching people and showing people
how to do the same whether they're
northerners or southerners
so you know to me you know what i'm
doing is i'm not trying to change the
market
change the economy i'm saying what's the
economy doing what are the
covered rules what are the rules what's
happening and how can i
just make money off the back of it which
is what being an entrepreneur is
and when you're making money of course
you're adding value you're solving
problems
so anyway um another reason that people
are criticizing the statute holiday
is because one of the reasons that
people have been fighting for the stamp
duty holiday to be extended
another few months is because everyone's
saying there's loads of first-time
buyers
that are in the process of buying a
house and
if the stamp due holiday ends on the
first of april there's going to be some
people
where they comp they might complete just
after that and it's going to mean that
they miss out and it's going to be
really annoying for them but i'm
thinking
i mean that is a bit of a crazy reason
to extend it because that's only going
to happen
at the end of june again you just have a
different batch of people so there's a
lot of controversy a lot of conversation
about this online
the media we're going crazy i'm pleased
that this happens because i think it's
going to it's going to
keep the market booming which is going
to be great for
property investors um i mean i'm right
right now i'm in the process of i'm
about to start um
hopefully we're completing on a piece of
land um in leeds where we're gonna be
building some
houses we're gonna be building some
apartments so if the market's going up
that's a really
good thing for me if you are
not buying houses and you're not going
to be ready to buy houses for another
year or two
it might be a bad thing because it means
by the time you come in
house prices will be too high now at
some point there's going to be a dip
in the market at some point when
furlough ends
and stamp due holiday ends the market
will dip
and i thought that that would have
happened already because i thought that
the lockdown would have finished by now
but the lockdown is still not finished
it's not been lifted but at some point
there's going to be a dip in the market
that is that is going to happen but
that's always the case
you know the property market goes up it
goes down it goes up it goes down it
goes up it goes down
but overall over time the housing market
will continue to go up
because we are on a small island there
is a massive shortage of houses
there's an overpopulation of people so
what i would say um
is is don't wait to buy a house buy a
house and wait
wait for the capital appreciation wait
for um
you know the income that you're making
but do it properly do it smart know what
you're doing get trained get educated
i'd love to know what you think about
the stamp sheet holiday are you pleased
are you disappointed
do you think it's a good move a bad move
let me know in the comments below
and i'll keep you posted on any news
updates so don't forget to subscribe
smash the like button turn the
notification bell on and i'll see you
very very soon with more updates